welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
vossen ant-man and the wasp hilariously
rescaled marvel's biggest dope
into its tiniest accidental jesus who
resurrected and saved us all the ant-man
sequels connections to avengers end game
and vfx magic fill it with interesting
easter eggs that was only able to find
in this
infinity song re-watch why haven't i
been doing that the whole time the whole
time
okay the film opens with janet van
dyke's goodbye to young hope
mommy jellybean it's going to be so
boring i won't be able to keep my
eyes
janet's bit here for shadows her
coma-like exile
with her drifting into the quantum realm
a kind of dream that she cannot wake up
from
here she stays fake asleep until hank
wakes her up from the bit
janet we gotta go just like he will
awaken her from the quantum realm in the
movie's climax janet nicknames hope
jellybean a parallel to scott nicknaming
his daughter cassie peanut this movie is
about hope's reunion with her mother and
her predecessor as the hero wasp
scott's role in the movie is to
facilitate that reunion which he does
literally as an
antenna and spiritually as a past
returning parent to cassie who
like hope will probably take on her
parents legacy as the future hero
stature we get a glimpse of that future
with scott and cassie playing heist for
the world's greatest grandma trophy
which we later learn is the hiding place
for the stolen ant-man suit
just like this whole movie is a heist
four stolen pimtec
and our man luis returns i'm the boss
i'm the boss
i'm the boss yeah yeah yeah yeah calling
back scott's flying during the airport
battle in civil war
those heroics landed scott under house
arrest with chickens by jimmy wu
close up magic
i learned that how'd you do it scott do
what
the car trick seriously as we'll see in
endgame scott kind of is marvel's ace in
a hole
vanishing and magically reappearing and
having to explain to everyone how
the hell he did it
you're getting good at that how'd you do
that it's got drums to pass the time we
actually saw him passing the time like
this in his cell in civil war and his
online magic school is taught by real
life magician michael carbonaro who says
snap your fingers that is misdirection
snaps so what you did there i thought we
wouldn't notice but we did but along
that side column are the words
micro magic misdirection and levitation
which if you think about it are all
tactics they use to bring down thanos
wanda maximoff levitates and nearly
kills him tony gets him with
misdirection and all this was made
possible
because scott brought micro magic to
this equation
scott sobs through the fault in our
stars you can actually see from the
pages of the book that he's close to the
end of it
right around when the saddest stuff
happens scott also watches a scene from
animal house
one tiny atom in my fingernail could be
one little tiny
universe obviously a parallel to the
quantum realm concept as a whole
also in the final shot they watch
another referency movie the 1954 giant
ant disaster movie them mr driven scott
wakes up and hopes
shrunken car and spends the next
sequence in his bathrobe a nod by
director peyton reed to the big lebowski
which actually has gotten referenced
with jeff bridges and easter eggs in the
first iron man
and tony's joke and end game one side
there lebowski like the big lebowski
ant-man the wasp is what's called
a shaggy dog story an over-complicated
yarn that
humorously but intentionally surrenders
to its own complications
in both movies the hero is a lovable
fool
with limited personal investment in the
plot who gets dragged into this messy
scheme while wearing his pjs and is just
trying to return to a status quo the
twisty plot of lebowski ends up being a
big misunderstanding by the end of this
movie we learn
practically nothing about sunny birch's
shady employers or the real mysteries
behind
janet's time in the quantum realm or the
fate of the villain ghost
it's all because it's from scott's point
of view and he doesn't really care about
any of that
it's cause scotty a huge pigeon eye
catches them off guard like the t-rex
eye in jurassic park there's actually
another jurassic park nod later
clever girl clever girl
scott explains his decision to join team
cap in civil war the cap needed help
tin america captain cap it's
what we call them if you're a friend
later in end game they call back this
moment when hope calls them cap
we're on it cap
hank pym's suitcase lab is made up of
blown-up toys and tools so that it'd be
functional when it's shrunken
it's powered by a giant duracell battery
the floors are pieces of erector sets
the wall panels are lego pieces though
knock off legos because they don't have
the official lego logo stamped on the
pieces oh they're knockoffs there's also
a volume knob
there's a light bulb there's a paperclip
clothes pin you can find in there
it is literally hey help me out with
this lebowski
the box of scraps i love how one of the
ants is buffing the floor
because when you're sucking [ __ ] through
a quantum tunnel the workspace needs to
stay clean
look my dudes losing your hair is a
bummer two out of three guys will
experience some form of male pattern
baldness by the time they're 35. we
don't want that
we want the hair on her head to never
age like paul rudd and his gorgeous mane
thanks dude he didn't need the quantum
realm to stay young forever that's what
we want for our head hair
well with keeps it's easier and more
affordable to get treatment for your
hair loss and help you keep the hair
they already have keeps offers generic
versions of the only two
fda approved hair loss products out
there but at half the cost of your local
pharmacy
you don't have to go to a doctor's
office you can do this all from home
where you're probably stuck right now
anyway you meet with a doctor online and
they ship the treatment right to your
home
find out why keep says more five-star
reviews than any of its competitors
and nearly a hundred thousand men trust
keeps for their hair loss prevention
medication so if you're noticing that
you're losing your hair
do something about it for a limited time
just go to keeps.com
new rockstars or click on the link in
the description to receive 50
off your first order sonny birch refers
to his employers
my buyers don't take no for an answer
and i have promised results to some
dangerous people
and again we never get the details about
who these buyers are
i have in the past suggested ozcorp but
said photos for the
loki series on disney plus have shown
roxon buses
maybe the time variance authority plot
with loki will connect to
roxanne's attempts to harness quantum
energy for
some time meddling related goals in the
fight
wasp runs across the knight blade and
right away
two more knives follow right behind it
meaning in normal speed this thrower
must have picked up and flung
knife two and three with lightning speed
and bullseye precision but to account
for this they actually bfxed the
throwers arm down
after his first throw to justify his
nearness to the knight for the second
throw
it's more great attention to detail here
after bursting through the bag of flour
hope shrunken down skids along that
spilled flower on the table ghost shows
up and successfully phase shifts through
most of wasps attacks
but she doesn't anticipate hope
weaponizing her wing
so she does take that hit kurt brings up
the baba yaga like a like a ghost
like baba yaga oh you don't find someone
like that
they find you like bubba yaga then later
in the movie he calls it back
at night little children sleepy tight
he's of course referring to the
boogeyman of russian folklore
also known as john wick they learn how
they can track the lab
the lab emits radiation could we modify
a quantum spectrometer and track it
ah yes quantum spectrometers are what
bruce banner used to track the tesseract
in the first avengers
how many spectrometers do you have
access to how many others call every lab
you know tell them to put the
spectrometers on the roof and calibrate
them for gamma rays
and they head to the college guys it's
not a good idea to be out in the open
like this
relax no one's gonna recognize us
what because of hats and sunglasses it's
not a disguise hank we look like
ourselves at a baseball game
poking a bit of fun at winter soldier
when world famous avengers disguise
themselves somehow with baseball hats
and glasses
and uh of course bill foster recognizes
hank immediately
in a dark lecture hall but then again
when scott helps hank escape custody a
hat and glasses disguise him
pretty well marvel morpheus lectures the
object in question would be both in and
out of phase
with multiple parallel realities he's
referring to ava's condition but also
given us a hint at how the quantum
realm's time vortexes lead
to new branch realities and on the
chalkboard behind him he's written the
word
matrix later on in the school the
chalkboard has words
ants grow some set dresser on this
movie's a real
goofball no i just got the haircut let's
not pull it all out
bill foster tells scott back in the day
i was hank's partner on a project called
goliath goliath of course is bill
foster's superhero name in the comics
and project goliath was the second mcu
shield operation from tony's line from
that iron man 2 deleted scene along with
project pegasus i need some stuff out of
storage
give me everything from projects pegasus
exodus and goliath roger pegasus being
the tesseract research leaving
that project exodus a mystery that i
made videos about i'm thinking it's
weapon x related scott's glitchy
resizing in the school has some
super inventive dfx work behind it they
constructed two different sized
backpacks a normal one that evangeline
lilly hands down
and a double sized one for paul rudd to
catch and there's a very subtle
cgi transition in those handoffs where
they switched the backpacks but rudd
distracts from that switch by fumbling
awkwardly with the oversized
bag similarly outside they rebuilt those
steps to match with the on location
camera movement but rudd's
childish one step at a time clinging to
that handrail flapping his other arm
around
tripping on the way to the van a little
bit all this behavior keeps the focus on
the gag
setting up hank's punchline hiya champ
how was school today
see all this is a good reminder that the
best vfx shots partner
technology with actor performance rather
than replacing it in the home of bill
foster they find ghosts
it's okay it's just the suit this big
empty suit
sets up scott's misdirection trick on
jimmy wu later
magic we find out that ava's father was
elias
starr and they gave this guy a shiny
bald head
a nod to eliastar's identity as the
villain egghead in the ant-man comics
so like hank pym and goliath the mcu is
keeping egghead as part of the older
generation of scientists
scott and hope discuss janet in the
quantum realm what if she's a completely
different person
indeed janet does later tell hank i'm
not the same woman i was 30 years ago
henry
they don't go too further into it but
quantum energy does seem to have some
mutating qualities to it luis's ringtone
is morrissey's every day is like sunday
called back later in luis's story oh my
willita had a box at the restaurant
yeah only played morsi luis also freaks
out about the expensive pastry
it's all like that fancy raspberry
filling represents the company's red and
we're days away from going out of
business
in the movies final montage xcon's new
business success
is reflected from that pastry box going
from the red
to blue janet inhabits scott's mind with
quantum entanglement
you have to meet me at these exact
coordinates in the wasteland
beyond the quantum void now this gives
us some geography for the quantum realm
like later when hank pym goes to rescue
her he's briefly
in that dark crystalline space that
scott was trapped in previously
but when hank goes deeper to burst
through that threshold
that's the quantum void and it's why
scott only ever saw shadows and
projections of janet before
and he never made it into those vibrant
planes scotch hats with cassie
so maybe you just need someone watching
your back
like a partner wait who did you think me
you don't laugh
i'd be a great partner cassie's hinted
at her future s stature which
might come sooner now that we have an
older emma furman playing the character
and also like many child actors doing
these movies she looked directly into
the camera
don't look at me scott helps hank escape
custody the same way hank helped him in
the previous film
using ants to cover the security camera
and sneaking in a suit for them one of
burch's guys sucks on his necklace
which comes back later when kurt tases
him the metal in his mouth
brings that electric current to his
teeth they take back the lab and ghost
confronts them
phasing through the doors yet one ripple
of her
pushes open those doors with her hands
even though she doesn't need to which is
interesting because ghost's alternate
phase shifting states might suggest
alternate realities layer on top of each
other like this now they all mostly
stick to the same track some are just
steps ahead or behind the main one but
considering she never got those quantum
healing particles after scott got
trapped in the post-credits scene i'm
curious to learn if ghost's alternate
faces make
further varying choices from her like
ghosts of alternate lives on alternate
paths than her i just
hope they didn't forget about her when
hank shrinks down to the tardigrades
level in his cockpit are a
turn coordinator in an artificial
horizon instruments that you would find
in a real pilot's cockpit that you
probably wouldn't need in a vehicle that
shrinks between atoms and everything's
getting like disoriented
also the panel behind him misspells the
label for vehicle
that's what happens when you build all
your tech with ants the others chase
each other throughout the hilly streets
of san francisco including the iconic
windy lombard street
all this evoking the iconic san
francisco card chase in the movie bullet
hoax shrinks a motorcycle and its engine
raises its pit
did you shrink stan lee's car well the
60s were fun but
now i'm paying for it and while the last
movie gave us a big mouse
this one gives us a big old kitty
hello tim hydeker cameos is the whale
watching tour guide
i love how scott kicks his legs keeping
them together to look like the fin of a
whale hank finds janet in the quantum
realm
notice how she turned one of her wasp
wings into a
spear type weapon and she wears these
hooded clothes
which most likely came from that doomed
city that you can barely make out in the
background
a deleted scene further elaborates on
janet's life
in this place there's so much we didn't
know about this place henry
worlds upon worlds entire civilizations
then right after this they encounter
this being passing through we stake no
claim
go in peace
interesting now we did go more into a
lot of these bigger secrets of the
quantum realm in the last big question
so go check it out on the tv news of big
ol scott
the chiron labels him giant hyphen man
which is
the first on-screen listing of ant-man's
alternate form from the comics when he's
big
janet returns to the surface and
embraces hope a similar emotional
reunion that scott will have with his
daughter after she grows older in
in-game
after he goes for that time vortex and
the post-credits scene that janet warns
him about
and don't get sucked into a time vortex
we won't be able to save you
well ant-man and the wasp was a shaggy
dog story that scott lang lebowski's
through he
witnesses the catharsis of a lost parent
reuniting with their child something he
experiences
and helps other avengers like tony stark
and thor feel
as they save the universe in endgame and
also leaves him with a future partner
that he can one day pass the torch to
join our next mcu watch along on discord
by becoming a patron at patreon.com
new rockstars we have a few more mcu
movies left but we're going to keep this
rewatch series going
starting with sam raimi's spider-man
voted number one on our channel poll and
we're gonna follow that with some others
requested by our
subscribers and our patrons so don't
worry follow me on instagram at eavos
follow new rockstars and i hope i can
trust you to subscribe to this channel
because
last time i trusted someone this
happened
[Music]
you